guys this is a truly historic moment for
the score eSports top 10s it's the first
time we've ever covered rocket League
now you guys have been asking for this
in the comments section for a long time
and let no one say we don't read the
comments right so let's get on with it
with the top ten goals from the our LCS
season six world championship kicking
off our list at number ten is we dem
girlz Remco taking on cloud nine and
game three of the winners quarter-final
we dem girls found themselves down early
but that didn't stop Remco from hitting
a sweet double tap in the corner to put
his team on the board the cloud nine is
reading the field we numb girls is
forced to keep the ball close to the
shot from Remco an excellent way to
finally get them on the board but is it
too little too late I definitely will
say it's too little too late but it's
all great I mean that is a tight angle
you can't find it much more difficult
than that carrying his way to the number
nine spot on our list is g2 esports
rizzo staring down a mixed european
squad and flipside tactics in the
winners quarter-finals Rizzo was already
putting on a clinic in this series and
immediately made his presence felt in
game 3 defense scrambling for flipside
Rizzo off the wall follow it up and that
is his fifth goal of this series so far
I mean we spend all this time talking
about granola ingenious but look at this
one the top of everyone and Rizzo gets
him started few players in rocket League
achieved the same consistency as
Dignitas as k-dog which is one of the
reasons he flies in at number eight on
our list hey Dom what double-tap playing
on the winners side of the Grand Finals
against cloud 9k top hit a slick double
tap to give dig a two-goal advantage in
Game four
go on for the clear but K table has
something else planned k not with the
DoubleTap Dignitas ahead by 2 this is
what we love to see out of this team
consistency and perfection paid off
following that he never misses those man
you can't stop him
one of the more interesting components
of rocket League is the mind games you
can play on your opponent and few things
showcase this better than we dem girls
met sonorous at our number seven spot
playing in the winners semi finals
against chief C sports club we dem girls
met sonorous faked out both drip-a and
commie before casually putting the ball
in the back of the net over his head
fantastic play from that sonorous tweet
them girls in the lead there is no
better stage to perform on and the grand
final of a world championship which is
why cloud nines gimmick comes in at
number 6 on our list after resetting the
grand finals bracket against Dignitas
the momentum was on c9 side and gimmick
wasted no time in placing an incredible
double tap Brightman might commit their
chance for cloud 9 gimmick can get a
strong shot go on for the dunk
[Applause]
[Applause]
everyone looking for the hard shots and
then he goes underneath the ball kate up
even trying to read that gotta feel good
giving his freestyling in the grand
final carbons coming in at number five
on our list is evil geniuses Chicago in
their first match of the tournament
North America's fourth seed were eager
to prove themselves on the world stage
and they did just that
a Chicago hit a stunner off painted
mines crossbar to put his team ahead
challenge setting another one on net but
Express will have that away in Chicago
again to the ceiling off the crossbar
puts that one in the back of the net and
evil geniuses with the one goal lead
right at halftime our number-4 spot is
proof that teamwork makes the dream work
playing in the lower bracket finals
against we dem girlz cloud9 found
themselves up 300 which gave gimmick and
squishy all the leeway they needed to
pull off this absolutely ridiculous
combo shot go demolish on offense he'll
spawn in the back
you heard them on the desk talking about
a wish hand gimmick tag tables worth
would not very often do I genuinely have
no clue Gold's bad to happen what on
earth swifty
the pace he had in his car but he was
still even depends get underneath it not
overshoot it floor goes up and it looks
like they're not stopping taking the
third spot on our list is n a's human
highlight reel himself
squishy muffins if there's ever a player
to do it it's going to be squishy
against we dem girls squishy muffin
shows us exactly why he's one of na
stomp talents Pharma gets this one away
squishes airborne keeping it here in the
midfield giving himself options he
pinches it if there's ever a player to
do it it's going to be squishy he gets
it he bounces up he gets the dunk with
the flip reset right at a game three
squishy we are all kuck here and it's
Kuck your signature shot that comes in
at number two on our list no you're a
big deal when you have a shot named
after you but pulling it off in a world
championship well that's something else
altogether that by squishy pinched off
the ceiling
[Music]
it's a beautiful play and you saw it in
the bed before the match is here
taking the number-one spot on our list
is a shot that sent the rocket league
world into a frenzy
[Applause]
after resetting the bracket against
back-to-back champions Dignitas in the
grand finals c9 were up three games to
one and found themselves in a 1-1
deadlock
that is until squishy muffins came
through with a goal that shocked the
rocket league world to its core
[Applause]
squishing cloud nine
there's the most talented mechanical
players there is in this game and he
pulls off a clip reset well guys that
was our first foray into rocket League
and be honest with me how do we do do we
hit the mark if we miss it let me know
in the comments below and don't forget
to indicate if you want more rocket
League content on our channel see you
next time if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]